I think I'm just going to talk. How long do they actually fucking talk for? Hey, everybody. This is Andrew Garfield, and I am this week's guest on a podcast that we can all debate whether it needs to exist. But I'm waiting here as most guests have to do, and I didn't realize how long you have to fucking wait.
我想我只是要开始说了。他们到底要他妈的聊多久？嘿，大家好。我是安德鲁·加菲尔德，我是本周播客的嘉宾，至于这个播客是否有存在的必要，我们大家都可以争论一番。但我像大多数嘉宾一样在这里等着，我没意识到竟然要他妈的等这么久。
But at some point in the near future, I will be talking to the guys who, Do small list. Welcome to small this. Jay, how was the boat ride? Yeah. Do you have to paddle? The world wants to know.
但在不久的将来，我会和那些家伙聊天，Small List。欢迎来到Small List。杰伊，船坐得怎么样？是啊。你得划船吗？全世界都想知道。
Respond publicly. How is the boat ride? There were so many. And then I guess I was saying, I think Schumer posted like a bunch of photos, Amy Schumer, not Chuck. Although Chuck Schumer's threatening to post some photos of you, too. I don't know what that's regarding. Yeah, there were many.
公开回应一下。船坐得怎么样？人太多了。然后我想我当时在说，我觉得舒默发了一堆照片，是艾米·舒默，不是查克。虽然查克·舒默也威胁要发一些你的照片。我不知道那是关于什么的。是啊，照片很多。
Many, many, many, many pictures being taken. It was, it was nice. What do you mean? I mean, it was like incredibly. It was nice. You're in the middle of directing. You got a little time off. And it was nice to get a time time off.
拍了好多好多好多照片。挺好的，挺好的。你什么意思？我是说，这简直……挺好的。你正忙着导演工作。你有一点空闲时间。能有空闲时间真好。
Yeah, but it was, these are all high class problems. You know, I just, you can't really relax because I'm not, I'm not done. I got to leave and frickin' 48 hours to go back to Iceland for a week of shooting and another 11-hour flight and another. nine-hour time change or more. My body's like, dude, what are you doing? Right. Chill.
是啊，但这都是些上流社会的问题。你知道，我真的没法放松，因为我还没忙完。我得在48小时内离开，去冰岛进行为期一周的拍摄，还要再坐11个小时的飞机，还要经历9个小时的时差，甚至更多。我的身体在说，老兄，你在干嘛？对。冷静点。
Well, listen, again, I hate to go back to it, but according to the shots, off the back of the boat, your body looks like it can handle just about anything. Yeah. Okay. Speaking of which, Willie, I saw some nice shots of you.
好吧，听着，我不想再提这个了，但根据船尾拍的照片来看，你的身体看起来什么都能应付。是啊。好吧。说到这个，威利，我看到你的一些好照片了。
You had your own little European boating vacation, eating grapes with a hard body of yours. Christ. Shani, I saw you posted a picture of you and Scotty. On the beach? Just keeping it real.
你也有自己的小型欧洲游艇度假，吃着葡萄，秀着你那硬朗的身材。天哪。沙尼，我看到你发了一张你和斯科蒂的照片。在海滩上？只是保持真实。
Up the north coast of California. Yeah, in the Malibu. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Well, you know, Will calls, will FaceTime me working out with no shirt on. Just regular conversation. Hey, what's going on? Doing dumbbells.
在加州北海岸。对，在马里布。对，对，对。嗯，你知道，威尔会跟我视频通话，光着膀子锻炼。就像普通的对话一样。嘿，在干嘛呢？在练哑铃。
I'm like, what can you, do you want to wait? Or do you want to talk now? No, I got to get it in. I got to get it in. And then you went, no, no, no, no, the phone called. You want to wait on that? No, because I thought about it. As soon as I lifted a dumbbell, I was like, oh, Sean.
我就说，你能不能，你想等会儿再打？还是现在就要聊？不，我得练完。我得练完。然后你说，不，不，不，不，电话响了。你想等那个吗？不，因为我考虑了一下。我一举起哑铃，我就想，哦，肖恩。
You know what I mean? I got to call Sean. A good, I was going to say it's victimless, but it's not entirely victimless. But, you know, I got this. So, by the way, I went a couple of weeks ago, because it's been a minute since we've all been together. I went and did this thing with our pal, Dave Letterman, who we all adore up in Montreal.
你知道我的意思吗？我得给肖恩打电话。本来我想说这是无受害者的，但也不完全是。但是，你知道，我搞定了。顺便说一下，我几周前去了，因为我们已经有一阵子没聚在一起了。我去了蒙特利尔，和我们都崇拜的朋友戴夫·莱特曼一起做了件事。
Oh, yeah, I saw the pictures of that. That looked rad. Yeah. Yeah, that's really cool. It's super fun. And we all adore him and revere him. The best. Yeah, the best.
哦，对，我看到那些照片了。看起来很棒。是啊。是啊，真的很酷。超级有趣。我们都崇拜他，敬仰他。最棒的。是啊，最棒的。
And Sean, he started, we spent, I told you this, but we spent maybe 12 minutes talking about Sean. Jay, you got like 30 seconds, like a passing glance. What? Yeah. But Sean got, and he's like. That's when you lost the audience. He's like, what about the thing that you gave, that you, Sean takes a lot of hits on the podcast. Yeah.
还有肖恩，他开始……我跟你说过这个，但我们花了大概12分钟聊肖恩。杰伊，你只有大概30秒，就像匆匆一瞥。什么？是啊。但肖恩得到了，然后他说。那就是你失去听众的时候。他说，那你给的那个东西呢，你，肖恩在播客里挨了不少骂。是啊。
Which we've discussed before. And I'm like. I said, Dave, Sean and I have had this conversation. If I didn't make fun of Sean, he'd think that I was mad at him. Totally. We had this conversation a million times here. And then I told him the story, J.B., of when we went to see Sean opening night of Hello Oscar at the Tabasco Theater,
我们之前讨论过。我说，戴夫，肖恩和我聊过这个。如果我不取笑肖恩，他会以为我生他的气。完全同意。我们在这里聊过一百万次了。然后我给戴夫讲了那个故事，杰比，就是我们去塔巴斯科剧院看肖恩《你好，奥斯卡》首演之夜的时候，
and he said, talk about a show! Hello Oscar. And how, you know, we joke around and blah, blah, blah, blah. And then Sean gives us his performance, and Jason turns around. I'm sitting right behind Jason. and he's got tears in his eyes, and he says he's ruined the podcast. Because he's so talented.
他说，谈谈演出吧！《你好，奥斯卡》。还有，你知道，我们开玩笑什么的。然后肖恩表演完了，杰森转过身来。我就坐在杰森后面。他眼里含着泪水，他说他毁了这档播客。因为他太有才了。
We disrespect him too much now we can't make fun of him. We can't make fun of him. He's too good. And I told that story to sort of whatever, a couple thousand people in this theater with Dave. And I said, so just so you know, we all are in awe of what Sean does. That's very nice.
我们现在太不尊重他了，没法取笑他了。我们没法取笑他了。他太棒了。我把那个故事讲给剧院里那几千人听，还有戴夫。我说，所以你们要知道，我们都对肖恩所做的一切感到敬畏。那太好了。
Don't blow it off, Sean. Take it. We've talked about this ad nauseum, but I appreciate it. I appreciate it. We talked about with Dave, and Dave has your back. Dave loves you. I love Dave too.
别把它当耳旁风，肖恩。接受吧。我们已经没完没了地谈过这个了，但我很感激。我很感激。我们和戴夫谈过，戴夫支持你。戴夫爱你。我也爱戴夫。
He walked in. He saw a Goodnight Oscar in London. You walked in and I go, do you want a sandwich? Something? And he goes, he goes, I have diabetes. So I was like, oh, shit. I had no idea and I'm making fun of his weight. Wait, truly?
他走进来。他在伦敦看了《晚安，奥斯卡》。你走进来，我说，你要三明治吗？还是什么？他说，他说，我有糖尿病。所以我当时就想，哦，该死。我完全不知道，我还在取笑他的体重。等等，真的吗？
He does or no? Yeah, yeah. Oh, no way. Yeah. And then Scotty and him were like, look, I got the pot on my shoulder. He's like, me too. And they were like, you know.
他有吗？是啊，是啊。哦，不会吧。是啊。然后斯科蒂和他们就像，看，我肩膀上有个罐子。他说，我也是。然后他们就像，你知道。
Speaking of Scotty, what about that article I sent you yesterday? The crisis going on in the, the gay community now with people who love bears. Like the problem with GLP-1s now that the bears are shaking. Yeah. Skinny bears now. They're going extinct.
说到斯科蒂，我昨天发给你的那篇文章怎么样？现在同性恋群体中关于那些喜欢“熊族”的人的危机。就像现在GLP-1药物的问题，熊族们都在发抖。是啊。现在是瘦熊了。他们快灭绝了。
Yeah. We've got to protect the bears. The skinny bears are called otters. You know, now they're turning on otters. Yeah. Oh, my God. Yeah, now they're turning into otters. If you see a bear, don't shoot, you know.
是啊。我们得保护熊族。瘦熊被称为“水獭”。你知道，现在他们开始转向水獭了。是啊。哦，天哪。是啊，现在他们变成了水獭。如果你看到一只熊，别开枪，你知道。
I mean, we got to keep. Unless it's going well. We got to keep. Unless he asks for it. All right, anyway. Well, so much other stuff to talk about, but we should probably get to it. Is this yours today, Shawnee?
我是说，我们得保持。除非进展顺利。我们得保持。除非他要求。好吧，总之。好吧，还有很多其他事情要聊，但我们可能应该开始了。这是你今天的吗，肖尼？
This is mine. You guys are going to be so excited. Jay, what if we were like, no, it's yours? No, that's happened before, I think. I know it has. You fumble through your notes. Guys, my guest today was born in Los Angeles and raised outside of London. Oh, I've got it.
这是我的。你们会非常兴奋的。杰伊，如果我们说，不，这是你的呢？不，我想以前发生过。我知道发生过。你翻着你的笔记。伙计们，我今天的嘉宾出生在洛杉矶，在伦敦郊外长大。哦，我知道了。
Who? No. He was a competitive gymnast. How about that? No. And a swimmer as a kid, but quit gymnastic after his 200-pound Russian coach sat on his back during the splits, and he thought, quote, this is not a childhood. He worked at Starbucks until they fired him for sitting down too much. His mom made him a Spider-Man costume for Halloween when he was three.
谁？不。他曾是一名竞技体操运动员。那个怎么样？不。小时候还练过游泳，但在他200磅重的俄罗斯教练在他做劈叉时坐在他背上后，他就退出了体操，他当时想，引用一下，“这不是童年。”他在星巴克工作，直到他们因为他坐得太多而解雇了他。他三岁时，他妈妈给他做了一套蜘蛛侠服装参加万圣节。
Years later, he got paid to wear one in three movies. It's the Uber-talented and very charming Andrew Garfield. Andrew Garfield, Maloney. Andrew Garfield, I was just talking about you. the other day we've never met nice to meet you. Were you saying nice things about him? I was.
多年后，他在三部电影里穿这套衣服拿到了报酬。他就是才华横溢且非常有魅力的安德鲁·加菲尔德。安德鲁·加菲尔德，马洛尼。安德鲁·加菲尔德，我前几天刚提到你。我们没见过面，很高兴见到你。你在说他的好话吗？是的。
I was showing off. There's a photo of you that came up on Instagram or something and you were wearing because I find myself defending some of the stuff that I wear and you were wearing a phenomenal zip-up from Alessay
我在炫耀。Instagram上出现了一张你的照片，你穿着……因为我发现自己在为我穿的一些东西辩护，而你穿着一件来自Alessay的绝妙拉链衫。
which I own a different one and I get a lot of shit for it and I was like, look at Andrew Garfield. This dude is cool. He looks so good and he's wearing an Lesse's zip-up so shut it. Was it like a vintage one?
我有一件不一样的，我因为那件衣服挨了不少骂，我就想，看看安德鲁·加菲尔德。这家伙真酷。他看起来太棒了，而且他穿着Lesse的拉链衫，所以闭嘴吧。那是复古款的吗？
Yeah, it looks so good. You know the one I'm talking about. It's so good. Yes, I do, yeah. Are you wearing the high shorts too? No, I wasn't wearing the high shorts. I can't pull off shorts generally, but particularly not high shorts. You got to be careful on us.
是啊，看起来太棒了。你知道我说的是哪一件。太棒了。是的，我知道，是啊。你也穿那种高腰短裤吗？不，我没穿高腰短裤。我通常穿不了短裤，尤其是高腰短裤。你得小心点。
It's really nice to be with you guys. I really love you guys. I love this show so much. And yeah, Will, we haven't met. I know Jason a bit. Sean, I don't think we've met ever either, but I feel like we should have because we're of the theater. Yeah, yeah, yeah. We will.
能和你们在一起真好。我真的很爱你们。我太喜欢这个节目了。还有，威尔，我们还没见过面。我认识杰森一点。肖恩，我觉得我们也没见过面，但我觉得我们应该见过，因为我们都是搞戏剧的。是啊，是啊，是啊。我们会见面的。
We'll do something. Thanks for having. I feel like my intro is a bit ominous. I felt like you guys got so sad at the Russian guy sitting on my back. And like this... You just go to the list of things. Oh, painful. The list of losses of my life as the kind of intro.
我们会找机会的。谢谢你们邀请我。我觉得我的开场白有点不祥。我觉得你们听到那个俄罗斯人坐在我背上时变得好难过。就像这样……你只是列出那些事情。哦，痛苦。我生命中失去的清单作为开场白。
I mean, when I read that, that made me laugh so hard when you're like... When you, as a child, you go, this is not a childhood. I have to leave. I was 13 with a very large Russian guy, you know, on me. And Will, I'm such a huge fan of yours as well. I'm just a fan of all of you. and I'm sorry, I'm a little overwhelmed to be like. Well, right back at you.
我是说，当我读到那个时，我笑得好大声，当你像……当你小时候，你说，这不是童年。我得离开。我当时13岁，一个非常壮的俄罗斯人，你知道，压在我身上。还有威尔，我也是你的超级粉丝。我只是你们所有人的粉丝。抱歉，我有点不知所措。好吧，彼此彼此。
Right back. Where are you? You're in a hotel room somewhere. What are you doing? You assume this is a hotel room, but I designed my house to feel like as familiar as a hotel room would. Oops. That was a little bit of a faux part early on there, Jason.
彼此彼此。你在哪？你在某个酒店房间里吗？你在干嘛？你以为这是酒店房间，但我把我的房子设计得和酒店房间一样熟悉。哎呀。杰森，刚才那有点失礼了。
But I know, this is, it's the Crosby Street Hotel Room 601, if anyone's interested. Wow, this is live. Wow, doors unlocked, ass up, doors open. By the way, I really, like, I hope you guys keep in all of the very platonic, homoerotic intro that you guys... It was like the most homoerotic you guys have gone in a while, I feel like... It's been a minute. It's been a minute. It's coming. There's more coming. Yeah.
但我知道，这是，这是克罗斯比街酒店601号房间，如果有人感兴趣的话。哇，这是直播。哇，门没锁，屁股朝上，门开着。顺便说一下，我真的，希望你们保留所有那些非常柏拉图式的、同性恋色彩的开场白……我觉得这是你们最近一段时间以来最同性恋色彩的一次……已经有一阵子了。已经有一阵子了。还在后面呢。是啊。
But it's a service you guys are providing, I think, for men around the world. Sean, you just have reminded me of my buddy, speaking of homoeroticism, my buddy who was on one of these dating sites. the not a grinder, but a different one that's even more just immediate hookup thing. Yeah, yeah.
但我觉得这是你们为全世界男性提供的服务。肖恩，说到同性恋色彩，你让我想起了我的哥们，我的哥们在这些约会网站上。不是Grindr，而是另一个更直接的约炮软件。是啊，是啊。
And he got on and the guy sent him a picture of himself with his butt in the air winking, winking, and he just wrote, howdy.
他上去之后，那个人给他发了一张自己屁股朝天眨眼的照片，眨眼，他只写了，“Howdy”（牛仔式的问候）。
And my buddy's like, no. Howdy? Swipe. Swipe. All right, so if you're in New York, you are promoting something. What are you promoting? Right now,
我哥们就想，不。Howdy？左滑。左滑。好吧，如果你在纽约，你就是在宣传什么。你在宣传什么？现在，
I'm promoting. a family film called The Magic Fire Away Tree, which is an Enid Blyton book that was made into a film by Simon Farnaby, who wrote the Paddington movies. But I'm also, something very different I'm promoting, is a Paul Greengrass movie called The Uprising, which is about the Peasants Revolt in the 1800s
我正在宣传。一部叫《魔法远方树》的家庭电影，那是伊妮德·布莱顿的书，由西蒙·法纳比改编成电影，他写过《帕丁顿熊》系列。但我还在宣传一些非常不同的东西，是一部保罗·格林格拉斯的电影，叫《起义》，是关于1800年代农民起义的，
and has a slightly different tone to it. Holy shit. Yeah. I read a few Enid Blighton books, and as a kid, I don't remember any peasant uprisings. Wait, that sounds like a very uncomfortable shoot. A peasant war film. I'm not imagining a lot of luxury on that one.
基调稍微有点不同。天哪。是啊。我读过几本伊妮德·布莱顿的书，小时候我不记得有什么农民起义。等等，那听起来是一次非常不舒服的拍摄。一部农民战争电影。我没法想象那部戏会有什么奢华感。
Walk us through the pain. Jason's just thinking, at the end, when you wrap, are you going to shower in the trailer? You don't want to use the water in the trailer. So now you've got to do the ride back to the hotel with the guy with this. Heavy fabrics. Oh, this fuck. Yeah, stinky, stinky fabrics.
带我们感受一下那种痛苦。杰森只是在想，最后，当你杀青时，你会去拖车里洗澡吗？你不想用拖车里的水。所以现在你得和那个家伙一起坐车回酒店，带着这个。厚重的布料。哦，该死。是啊，臭烘烘的布料。
Chuck Schumer is definitely not waiting for me on a yard. in any kind of court at the end of a shoot day. Where did you shoot that? We were in Munich. We were in Munich. We were shooting, because there's a lot of medieval architecture
查克·舒默绝对不会在拍摄结束后的任何院子里等我。你在哪里拍的？我们在慕尼黑。我们在慕尼黑。我们在拍摄，因为那里有很多中世纪建筑，
still in Germany, weirdly. So we were shooting around. We were mostly in one field in Munich that was being doubled for a lot of different peasants fields in Munich. It was miserable. But in that way of the best possible misery.
奇怪的是，在德国依然存在。所以我们在周围拍摄。我们大部分时间都在慕尼黑的一个田野里，那个田野被当作慕尼黑许多不同农民的田野。很痛苦。但那是那种最好的痛苦。
And you guys love Paul's movies. Yeah, of course. Captain Phillips and the Bourne movies and News of the World. He's just like an incredible filmmaker. Yeah. And he's one of those team captains that kind of makes you want to suffer for him. You know what I mean? Where it's like, oh, no, I want to suffer as much as possible for this man
你们都喜欢保罗的电影。是啊，当然。还有《菲利普船长》、《谍影重重》系列和《世界新闻》。他简直是一位不可思议的电影制作人。是啊。他是那种让你愿意为他受苦的团队队长。你知道我的意思吗？就是那种，哦，不，我愿意为这个人受尽可能多的苦，
because he's going to... Because he's driving, yeah? Yeah. I was going to say, Jason, would you say that Woody and Sam are saying that they're suffering for you right now? Is that a fair assessment of what they're going through? Yeah. They're just trying to keep me awake. No, no.
因为他会……因为他在掌舵，是吗？是啊。我本来想说，杰森，你会说伍迪和萨姆现在说他们为你受苦吗？这是一个公平的评估吗？是啊。他们只是在努力让我保持清醒。不，不。
But he's, yeah, Paul Greengrass is, does seem like one of those guys who, it's an all-in venture. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. It was an amazing, it's a really good group of actors as well. It's Tom Hollander, who's incredible, and Jamie Bell and Cosmo Jarvis, Catherine Waterston, Stephen Delane,
但他，是啊，保罗·格林格拉斯看起来确实是那种全情投入的人。是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。那也是一群很棒的演员。有汤姆·霍兰德，他不可思议，还有杰米·贝尔、科斯莫·贾维斯、凯瑟琳·沃特斯顿、斯蒂芬·迪兰，
like a kind of murderers row of great British actors, and it's like a proper ensemble. And it's like this historical drama, but he's shooting it like he shoots, which is all handheld. You're in the action. You're kind of viscerally with the characters. And it's powerful. And it goes like a freight train. It's like a very like fast-paced historical drama.
就像一排伟大的英国演员，这就像一个真正的群戏。这是一部历史剧，但他拍摄的方式和他一贯的风格一样，全是手持摄影。你身处动作之中。你从内心深处与角色同在。这很有力量。而且它像货运列车一样前进。这是一部节奏非常快的历史剧。
Can I just say another sort of aside? Can I just, you mentioned Stephen Delane. And I've said this before. This is one of the most underrated actors of our time, Stephen Delaide. 100%. He's an incredible. where would I know him from? I mean, a million things.
我能再说一个题外话吗？我能，你提到了斯蒂芬·迪兰。我之前说过。这是我们这个时代最被低估的演员之一，斯蒂芬·迪兰。100%。他是一位不可思议的……我会在哪里认识他？我是说，一百万件事。
I'd know his face if I saw him. 100%. 100%. He's breathtakingly incredible, right? Andrew, am I right about that? No, he is one of the greats. And it's one of those careers where you're like, oh man, that's kind of the dream
如果我看到他的脸，我会认出来的。100%。100%。他令人惊叹地不可思议，对吧？安德鲁，我说得对吗？不，他是伟大的演员之一。这是那种你会觉得，哦，天哪，那简直是梦想的职业生涯，
where Jason Bateman doesn't exactly know who I am. Yeah. Do you know? Where it's like, he knows that I'm great, but he doesn't know anything about me or my personal life. But he would definitely cost me in a rude-r-r-ranging. How is spelling it? Stephen D-E-E-L-L-L-L-A-N-E.
杰森·贝特曼并不完全知道我是谁。是啊。你知道吗？就是那种，他知道我很棒，但他对我或我的个人生活一无所知。但他绝对会雇我。怎么拼写？S-T-E-P-H-E-N D-E-L-A-N-E。
Jay, you know, your wife loves him, lay breaking. And he was in the English version of, when they did the bridge that Swedish-D-N-S-S-S-O-N-S-O-N-S-O, and they made it called The Tunnel. It was a UK-French cop-pro. I like saying, cop-pro, it makes me sound like I know what I'm talking about. For sure. And I remember talking about him with Amanda
杰伊，你知道，你妻子爱他，Lay Breaking。他出演了瑞典版《桥》的英国版，他们把它叫《隧道》。那是一部英法合拍片。我喜欢说“合拍片”，这让我听起来好像我很懂行。当然。我记得和阿曼达谈论过他，
and just both of us just going like, this guy is incredible. I mean, he's amazing. Do you find him, Jay? The tunnel, the TV series? Yeah, because your spelling on Delane was terrible. How much more time do we have? No, it's like Dill Pickle.
我们俩都觉得，这家伙太不可思议了。我是说，他太棒了。你觉得他怎么样，杰伊？《隧道》那部电视剧？是啊，因为你拼写迪兰拼得太烂了。我们还有多少时间？不，就像酸黄瓜（Dill Pickle）。
Guys, welcome Stephen Delane. Here he is. Andrew, how good your Stephen Delane impression? There he is. Oh, no, I'm not much of a fan of this. guy. No. Could you imagine after all that?
伙计们，欢迎斯蒂芬·迪兰。他来了。安德鲁，你的斯蒂芬·迪兰模仿秀有多好？他来了。哦，不，我不太喜欢这个家伙。不。你能想象在这一切之后吗？
See, guys, I had to make it worth it. No, he's a rock star. I see. I see what you're saying, yes. This is a guy. You see him in any project. You're like, oh, we're in good hands here. Yeah, yeah.
看，伙计们，我得让它物有所值。不，他是摇滚明星。我明白了，我明白你的意思了，是的。这是一个家伙。你在任何项目中看到他。你都会想，哦，我们在这里很安全。是啊，是啊。
Yeah, he's amazing. Well, but, you know, I was going to wait to the end to talk about this, Andrew, but since we're talking about projects. We are at the end now after all. of that Stephen Delay in Google search. Exactly. No, but two projects I thought are really, really cool. One is by a friend of mine you called Wild Things.
是啊，他太棒了。好吧，但是，你知道，我本来想等到最后再谈这个，安德鲁，但既然我们在谈项目。在那个斯蒂芬·迪兰的谷歌搜索之后，我们现在确实到最后了。没错。不，但有两个项目我觉得真的，真的非常酷。一个是我的朋友叫《狂野事物》。
Will you play Roy of Sigfried and Roy? John Hoffman. Are you friends with John? Yeah, John Hoffman, yep. Love John Hoffman. Yeah, he's the best. Oh, wow, yeah, you just finished working with Jude. Yeah, we just did.
你扮演齐格飞与罗伊里的罗伊？约翰·霍夫曼。你和约翰是朋友吗？是啊，约翰·霍夫曼，是的。爱死约翰·霍夫曼了。是啊，他是最棒的。哦，哇，是啊，你刚和裘德合作完。是啊，我们刚做完。
You play Sigreed and Roy, which is awesome. Yeah, it's, I'm excited about it. It's, as you imagine and more, It's like more is more is more is more with those two. You know, the gay German magicians in the desert and with the tigers and the lions. That old story. That old classic tale, that old myth.
你扮演齐格飞和罗伊，这太棒了。是啊，我很兴奋。正如你想象的那样，甚至更多，对那两个人来说，更多就是更多，更多就是更多。你知道，沙漠里的同性恋德国魔术师，还有老虎和狮子。那个老故事。那个老经典传说，那个老神话。
They've been told of time and again. But fucking hell, these guys were truly not. Well, the guy I play was truly insane. Roy Horn. He was the tiger magician, but literally believed and was convinced and maybe truly did have some spiritual connection to his tigers, to animals generally.
他们被一次又一次地讲述。但该死的，这些家伙真的不是。好吧，我扮演的那个家伙真的疯了。罗伊·霍恩。他是那个老虎魔术师，但真的相信，并且确信，也许真的与他的老虎，与动物普遍有着某种精神联系。
Did you use real animals? No, no, no, we're not legally allowed to do that. I did feed a tiger with my hand. Yeah, I don't know. That's like people I've got. Wait, did you, was one of them mauled? Forgive me. Yeah, of course.
你们用真动物了吗？不，不，不，法律不允许我们那样做。我确实用手喂过一只老虎。是啊，我不知道。那就像人们……等等，其中一只被咬伤了吗？原谅我。是啊，当然。
Yeah, no, you're forgiven. You're forgiven. We don't say mold. We don't say mold, though. Well, we say there was an incident. there was a thing that happened. There was an event. Was it your character that had the event?
是啊，不，你被原谅了。你被原谅了。我们不说“咬伤”。我们不说“咬伤”。好吧，我们说发生了一起事故。发生了一件事。发生了一个事件。是你的角色发生了那个事件吗？
Yeah, Roy, yeah. The guy who had the magical connection to. Jason, Jason, Jason, Jason. Jason. He ate his face off or something, didn't he? Oh, Sean. Oh, sorry. I just read, I just read that he ate his face off.
是啊，罗伊，是啊。那个和……有着神奇联系的家伙。杰森，杰森，杰森，杰森。杰森。他把他的脸吃掉了还是什么的，对吧？哦，肖恩。哦，抱歉。我只是读到，我只是读到他把他的脸吃掉了。
Creating new myths. No, there was an incident. So what's remarkable about it is, I know, of course I'm defending him because I feel like I am his representative on this earth. So 40 years he worked with these animals, and there was no incident with him ever. And there was one night in 2003 where the tiger went tiger and decided, for whatever reason that night, that he was going to bite down on his master's neck and drag him to his cage.
创造新的神话。不，发生了一起事故。所以值得注意的是，我知道，我当然在为他辩护，因为我觉得我是他在这个地球上的代表。所以他与这些动物共事了40年，他从未发生过任何事故。2003年的一个晚上，老虎突然兽性大发，出于某种原因，决定咬住主人的脖子并把他拖回笼子。
And there's lots of different kind of theories about why the tiger, how do you, a tiger is a tiger, how can you, you know, you have no idea. But there are lots of theories, and one of the things that the show explores is why, on this particular night, did things go wild? But he survived it. His face is intact.
关于老虎为什么，你怎么，老虎就是老虎，你怎么能，你知道，你根本不知道。但有很多理论，节目探讨的事情之一就是为什么，在那个特定的夜晚，事情会失控？但他活下来了。他的脸完好无损。
But then he died during COVID. He, like, recovered. He did lots of rehab. They kind of, they got back on stage with the tigers. They were savages. They were, like, just these incredible kind of, like, gay German warrior magicians. They were, like,
但后来他在新冠期间去世了。他，就像，康复了。他做了很多康复训练。他们就像，他们带着老虎回到了舞台上。他们是野蛮人。他们就像，只是这些不可思议的，就像，同性恋德国战士魔术师。他们就像，
Some of the strongest. Roy particularly was this kind of, I don't know, monster. He was an amazing, amazing man. Wow. Oh, I can't wait to see that. Wait, but Andrew, you're also playing. And then, by the way, then we'll be done because you have 18 other projects, which is really exciting.
一些最强壮的。罗伊特别是一种，我不知道，怪物。他是一个了不起，了不起的人。哇。哦，我迫不及待想看那个了。等等，但安德鲁，你还在扮演。然后，顺便说一下，我们就结束了，因为你还有18个其他项目，这真的很令人兴奋。
But you're playing artificial. You play Sam Altman in a movie. Was he on the yacht with you, Jason? Was Sam on the yacht? He was on a boat nearby. Yeah. So for Tracy, Sam Altman created Chat Chip-T. He created Open AI.
但你正在扮演人工智能。你在一部电影里扮演萨姆·奥特曼。他在游艇上和你在一起吗，杰森？萨姆在游艇上吗？他在附近的一艘船上。是啊。所以对于特雷西来说，萨姆·奥特曼创造了Chat GPT。他创造了Open AI。
And so... at GPT. That's really cool, man. I mean, that's going to be a really great story. That's the Luca Guadagnino. You got it, yeah, yeah, yeah. I'm nervous about that one. I'm really scared about that one.
所以……GPT。那真的很酷，伙计。我是说，那会是一个非常棒的故事。那是卢卡·瓜达尼诺的电影。你猜对了，是啊，是啊，是啊。我对那个感到紧张。我真的很害怕那个。
What about the backlash? Well, yeah, I mean, like, you're playing one of arguably... You guys take a point of view on it? I mean, one, I hope we've taken a point of view on it, and it will be, you know, seen, and people will have their own opinions about it, but yeah, I mean, like, playing one of the, arguably the most... powerful people on this planet right now or interpretation of whoever this person.
关于反弹呢？嗯，是啊，我是说，就像，你扮演的是可以说……你们对此有观点吗？我是说，第一，我希望我们对此有观点，而且它会被，你知道，看到，人们会有他们自己的看法，但是的，我是说，扮演可以说……这个星球上目前最……强大的人之一，或者对这个人的诠释。
I have no idea. I've never met Sam Multman. I don't know anything about the interior of his soul. I just had to do something. I had to interpret what I understood, what I saw, what I read, what I, you know, I don't know what my imagination gave me, what the script gave me, but it's like he could definitely, he probably has hacked my phone and he probably is observing every move I make. Does the film take a position that this is something either ominous
我不知道。我从未见过萨姆·奥特曼。我对他灵魂的内部一无所知。我只是必须做点什么。我必须诠释我所理解的，我所看到的，我所读到的，我所，你知道，我不知道我的想象力给了我什么，剧本给了我什么，但这就像他绝对可以，他可能已经黑了我的手机，他可能正在观察我的一举一动。这部电影是否采取了立场，认为这是某种不祥的，
or something that is positive or what position? I think it focuses on him getting kind of ousted from the company and then back into the company, right? Yeah, that's part of it. I think I would hesitate to kind of preamble to be. I kind of want people to watch it and to find their position. I hope we're not villainizing anyone
还是某种积极的，或者什么立场？我觉得它侧重于他被赶出公司，然后又回到公司，对吧？是啊，那是其中的一部分。我想我会犹豫是否要为它做序。我有点想让人们去看它，然后找到他们的立场。我希望我们没有把任何人妖魔化，
or making anyone into a hero. I hope it's what Lucas films do. He gets into the gray area of what it is to be human, obviously. Don't you think it's wild? You're going to be part of that, and you're part of the other kind of big, you know, tech movement with social network, which you were great in. Do you want to tell Will and Jason,
或者把任何人变成英雄。我希望这是卢卡电影所做的那样。他深入探讨了作为人类的灰色地带，显然。你不觉得这很疯狂吗？你将成为其中的一部分，而且你是另一个大型，你知道，科技运动的一部分，就是《社交网络》，你在里面表现得很棒。你想告诉威尔和杰森，
or do you want me to tell Will and Jason what a woman once... Don't tell Jason. What a woman once tweeted about... your laptop smashing scene. I'm happy for you to share this. Okay. I mean, it's something like she wanted you to, she wanted you to smash your laptop on her tits or something.
还是你想让我告诉威尔和杰森，一个女人曾经……别告诉杰森。一个女人曾经发推特说……你砸笔记本电脑的那一幕。我很乐意让你分享这个。好吧。我是说，大概是她想让你，她想让你把笔记本电脑砸在她的胸部上什么的。
Oh, yeah. Because she, wow, I got to rewatch that. Yeah, yeah. Is that it? Hang on, let me pull that up real quick. I mean, that is insane. We know how fast you are at Google, so. My dial-up service is not what it was.
哦，是啊。因为她，哇，我得重看一遍。是啊，是啊。是那样吗？等等，让我快速查一下。我是说，那太疯狂了。我们知道你用谷歌有多快，所以。我的拨号上网服务不如以前了。
Wait, she, she's, she's, She tweeted that she wanted to smash her. Then she was serious, and then you met her. No way. Yeah, that's crazy. She showed up at a Q&A. And she was holding a sign saying, I'm the one that wants you to smash a laptop on my tits.
等等，她，她，她发推特说她想砸她的。然后她是认真的，然后你见到了她。不会吧。是啊，那太疯狂了。她出现在一个问答环节。她举着一个牌子说，我就是那个想让你把笔记本电脑砸在我胸部上的人。
Wow, did she ask you a question at this T&A, Q&A? Nice, nice, nice. Guys, it's low hanging fruit, still fruit. Low hanging fruit is still fruit. We will be right back. And now, back to the show. So wait, so that is a particularly... Now, Social Network is one of my favorite movies.
哇，她在这次问答环节问了你一个问题吗？不错，不错，不错。伙计们，这是唾手可得的果实，依然是果实。唾手可得的果实依然是果实。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。所以等等，所以那是一个特别……现在，《社交网络》是我最喜欢的电影之一。
I don't recall a particularly memorable level of hotness while you're destroying a laptop. Was there? Did you do it in, like, a hot way? I guess it's subjective, and I guess it's not something that you're into, Jason, and that's okay. Was your top off or something when you did it? No, it was just full of the power. powerful, like, justice seeking. Fincher didn't say,
我不记得你在摧毁笔记本电脑时有什么特别令人难忘的性感程度。有吗？你是以一种性感的方式做的吗？我想这是主观的，我想这不是你感兴趣的东西，杰森，那没关系。你做的时候是光着上身还是什么的？不，那只是充满了力量。强大的，就像，追求正义。芬奇没说，
Fincher wasn't like, hey, you're going to smash the left of. Hey, let's go tarps off on this one, huh? Hey, Garfield, you're going to go tarps off on this, eh? Can you get your nips hard real quick? Let's roll, let's roll, eh? Can we get some ice for Andrew? Well, let's roll, eh? Let's get this fired up here.
芬奇没说，嘿，你要砸左边的。嘿，我们这次脱掉上衣吧，嗯？嘿，加菲尔德，你要脱掉上衣做这个，嗯？你能让你的乳头快速变硬吗？开始吧，开始吧，嗯？能给安德鲁弄点冰块吗？好吧，开始吧，嗯？让我们把它点燃吧。
Let's go tarps off on Garfield on one. It's tarps off. There's no way that David Fincher would have been as successfully as he is if he was Canadian. There's no way. There's no way. I'm realizing that in real time. Wait, what about...
让我们在加菲尔德身上脱掉上衣。是脱掉上衣。大卫·芬奇如果是个加拿大人，绝对不会像现在这样成功。不可能。不可能。我正在实时意识到这一点。等等，关于……
But Jason, have you not seen the outtake of Andrew doing... And I'm not even kidding. How many takes and how many laptops did you smash? No, I haven't seen that. I think it was... I don't know. 30, 40... I don't know. 30 laptops.
但杰森，你没看过安德鲁做那个的删减片段吗？我甚至不是在开玩笑。你拍了多少次，砸了多少台笔记本电脑？不，我没看过。我想是……我不知道。30，40……我不知道。30台笔记本电脑。
Smashed. 30 laptops, yeah. Yeah, you haven't been to those rage rooms. You ever done like a rage room where you get like a baseball bat and you get given a bunch of shit to smash up. No. Yeah.
砸碎了。30台笔记本电脑，是啊。是啊，你没去过那些愤怒屋。你做过那种愤怒屋吗，就是你拿一根棒球棍，然后给你一堆东西让你砸碎。不。是啊。
Where are those? You have some? No, I mean, I know of it. I have never. I want to smash stuff? It's a, yeah, it's a great. It's a place that you can go. Sean, would you like Andrew to come over and,
那些在哪里？你有吗？不，我是说，我知道。我从来没有。我想砸东西？这是一个，是啊，这是一个很棒的。这是一个你可以去的地方。肖恩，你想让安德鲁过来，
you have a couple laptops that need smashing up, don't you? And I have tips, so I'm all in. Hard drives need to be erased. All right, but you did a family film that you're promoting now. And what, do you, do you got, do you got any little, oh, well, wait, I've gotten into trouble asking this before. I was going to ask you if you have any kids. Am I allowed to ask that?
你有几台笔记本电脑需要砸碎，对吧？而且我有小费，所以我全心投入。硬盘需要被擦除。好吧，但你现在正在宣传一部家庭电影。而且，你，你有，你有任何小，哦，好吧，等等，我以前问过这个惹过麻烦。我本来想问你是否有孩子。我被允许问那个吗？
How dare you? Honestly, how could you? What are you going to ask next? My age? What is this? I didn't think I was coming on the patriarchy podcast. Maybe some people don't. The handmaid's tail fucking.
你怎么敢？老实说，你怎么能这样？你接下来要问什么？我的年龄？这是什么？我没想到我是来参加父权制播客的。也许有些人不。使女的故事他妈的。
It's my bad. I apologize. I'm 42 and I'm childless. And I'm not entirely proud of that. Like I would love to have kids. I would love to start a family. It's just not. You offered that.
是我的错。我道歉。我42岁，没有孩子。而且我并不完全为此感到自豪。我是说我很想有孩子。我很想组建一个家庭。只是没有。你提供了那个。
I didn't ask that. Well, you kind of did. You kind of did. But so, because usually you hear about folks doing a family film because, well, you know, I do stuff my kids can't see. And so I want to finally do a movie that my kids can see. That's usually the story you hear. Sounds just like him, yeah. Right?
我没问那个。好吧，你确实问了。你确实问了。但所以，因为通常你听说人们拍家庭电影是因为，好吧，你知道，我做了一些我的孩子看不到的东西。所以我终于想拍一部我的孩子能看的电影。那通常是你听到的故事。听起来就像他，是啊。对吧？
Yeah. This, you just, you love this book. Well, no, you know what? I love Simon Farnaby. I love those Paddington movies so much. And I've been like an advocate for the, I love those films. And Simon is just a great, heartfelt comedy writer. And I had been wanting to do something a little easier in a way, to be honest.
是啊。这个，你只是，你喜欢这本书。好吧，不，你知道吗？我爱西蒙·法纳比。我太喜欢那些《帕丁顿熊》电影了。我一直是那些电影的拥护者，我爱那些电影。西蒙是一位伟大的、真诚的喜剧作家。老实说，我一直想做一些稍微容易一点的事情。
Is that okay to say? Yes, I just kind of wanted to have a nice time. Instead of throwing potatoes at peasants and stuff. You want to do something on a soundstage, right? I needed a break from throwing potatoes in peasants. Thank you, so. It's the first one I feel really understood, Jason. Yeah, no, it was really lovely.
可以说吗？是的，我只是想度过一段美好的时光。而不是向农民扔土豆什么的。你想在摄影棚里做点什么，对吧？我需要从向农民扔土豆中休息一下。谢谢，所以。这是第一个我觉得真正被理解的，杰森。是啊，不，这真的很可爱。
It was just a lovely time. And it's heartfelt. And it's about, you know, getting kids back in touch with themselves, with each other, with nature, with their own nature, with the family unit, with community. And, you know, it's not anti-technology, but there's a kind of like a kind of an awareness around how technology may or may not be screwing things up for us. And it's just lovely. And I have nephews and I have Godkids. And there was something very sweet about making this film and having my friends. friends who have young kids come and see it.
这只是一段美好的时光。而且它很真诚。它是关于，你知道，让孩子们重新与自己、与彼此、与自然、与他们自己的天性、与家庭单位、与社区建立联系。而且，你知道，它不是反技术的，但有一种关于技术可能如何或可能不会把事情搞砸的意识。而且它只是很可爱。我有侄子，我有教子。制作这部电影并让我的朋友们，那些有小孩的朋友们来看它，感觉非常甜蜜。
And it was like the best reviews I've ever had in my life. It was like, yeah, honestly, well, like it was like voice note after voice note after voice note of just raves from the seven, eight, nine, ten-year-olds that I have a connection. It was honestly like, why have I done anything other than this up until now? Because this is so much more pleasurable. I have had that experience.
这是我一生中得到过的最好的评价。就像，是啊，老实说，就像是一条接一条的语音信息，全是来自我认识的七、八、九、十岁孩子们的狂热评价。老实说，就像，为什么我到现在为止除了这个什么都没做？因为这比那愉快多了。我有过那种经历。
You guys have, too, when you do stuff that is more sort of family-oriented and whatever, the response is pretty rat. And when you meet a kid who's, like, super into something that you did, it's so much more gratifying. We're just watching their minds get blown when they're introduced. Like, Will, I bet a million times you've done, like, Lego Batman voice for a young kid, and they're like, wait, what?
你们也有过，当你做一些更偏向家庭导向的事情时，反应相当不错。当你遇到一个超级喜欢你所做的事情的孩子时，这要令人满足得多。我们只是看着他们的思想在被介绍时被震撼。就像，威尔，我敢打赌你有一百万次为一个小孩子做乐高蝙蝠侠的声音，他们会说，等等，什么？
I don't understand. Their mind kind of breaks a little bit. Yeah, and sometimes people, you know, come up to you, and you're with your kids, and you're getting ice cream out here with my kids or whatever, and somebody comes up and, want to say how you're like hey but when it's a kid who comes up in that way and is and is like a big fan of like as you say like lego batman or something it is very gratifying really in a different way or like when a kid comes up and says i don't know i have no idea who you are yeah i don't know
我不明白。他们的思想有点崩溃了。是啊，有时人们，你知道，走过来，你和你的孩子在一起，你在这里和我的孩子吃冰淇淋什么的，有人走过来，想说你像嘿，但当一个孩子以那种方式走过来，并且是像你说的像乐高蝙蝠侠之类的超级粉丝时，这在不同层面上确实非常令人满足。或者像当一个孩子走过来并说，我不知道，我根本不知道你是谁。是啊，我不知道
what you are when you when you did um you were a kid who do you think they thought you were right jason yes jason one time burned me the greatest burn that i'm super jealous of i told this huge story about, we were with on stage with Matt, Damon, and I told this story about Brad Pitt, you know, complimenting this thing and how I psyched I was, blah, blah, blah, blah, and I was like gushing like a little kid. And Jason paused, Jason goes,
当你做……你是一个孩子，你觉得他们以为你是谁，对吧，杰森？是的，杰森有一次给了我最棒的打击，我超级嫉妒。我讲了这个巨大的故事，关于，我们和马特·达蒙在舞台上，我讲了这个关于布拉德·皮特的故事，你知道，称赞这件事，以及我有多兴奋，等等，等等，我像个小孩子一样滔滔不绝。杰森停顿了一下，杰森说，
who do you think he thought you were? After getting a compliment from Brad Pitt? Yeah, which was so good. I was so jealous of that burn. So, Andrew, tell me about growing up. You were born in Los Angeles, but how did you then grow up in England? Because you were born here? Yeah.
你觉得他以为你是谁？在得到布拉德·皮特的称赞之后？是啊，这太好了。我太嫉妒那个打击了。所以，安德鲁，告诉我关于你的成长经历。你出生在洛杉矶，但你是怎么在英国长大的？因为你出生在这里？是啊。
Yeah, my mom. My mom is from Essex, from England. She met my dad in London, and then, my dad's from L.A. It's a longer story. But we don't have time. We don't have time. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. We, yeah, so they met in London. My dad was from L.A. He moved back to L.A. with her, had me and my brother. And we were living in Marina del Rey in the 80s, which. was not Marina del Rey now. And my mother was a kind of small town girl from the outskirts of London now suddenly in the middle of gang warfare and Marina Del Rey. And the Cheesecake Factory, let's not forget about that.
是啊，我妈妈。我妈妈来自英国埃塞克斯。她在伦敦遇到了我爸爸，然后，我爸爸来自洛杉矶。这是一个更长的故事。但我们没时间了。我们没时间了。我在开玩笑。我在开玩笑。我在开玩笑。我们在，是啊，所以他们在伦敦相遇。我爸爸来自洛杉矶。他带着她搬回了洛杉矶，有了我和我哥哥。我们在80年代住在玛丽安德尔湾，那，不是现在的玛丽安德尔湾。我母亲是一个来自伦敦郊区的小镇女孩，现在突然置身于玛丽安德尔湾的帮派战争中。还有芝士蛋糕工厂，别忘了那个。
Is the Cheesecake Factory been there since 83? And there was a Jerry's Deli too. There was a nice Jerry's Deli there. Oh, wait. She painted a much more kind of brutal picture of Marinee Del Rey. You're calling my mother a liar? Is that way of calling my mother a liar? We've heard.
芝士蛋糕工厂从83年就在那里了吗？还有一个杰瑞熟食店。那里有一个不错的杰瑞熟食店。哦，等等。她描绘了一幅更残酷的玛丽安德尔湾的画面。你在说我母亲是个骗子吗？这是说我母亲是个骗子的方式吗？我们听说过。
Jason, you pants me once in the parking lot of that Jerry's telling. Well, you're going to wear sweatpants, you're going to lose them. And I was wearing sweatpants. We were going to work. We paused outside the restaurant, and then he pantsed me in the middle.
杰森，你在那个杰瑞熟食店的停车场扒过我一次裤子。好吧，你要穿运动裤，你就会失去它们。我当时穿着运动裤。我们要去工作。我们在餐厅外停下来，然后他在中间扒了我的裤子。
Your luck I didn't tip you over afterwards, either. What year was this? When was, how old are you guys? This was 2004. We were 34, 35. We were all hopped up from cake from the cheesecake factory. And you weren't losers. You were like, cool guys.
你走运我没把你推倒。这是哪一年？你们多大？这是2004年。我们34、35岁。我们都因为芝士蛋糕工厂的蛋糕而兴奋不已。你们不是失败者。你们就像，酷家伙。
I don't know, cool guys. And then you did, when you got into gymnastics, I was in gymnastics, too, I did the, I was good at the pommel horse and like the floor events and stuff. Yeah, but I didn't stick with it. But, Sean, in a pinch, could you do like a backward handspring, like a flip right now? I can do like a roundoff of cartwheels now at this stage, but I could do all that stuff when I was younger, yeah, just for a little bit.
我不知道，酷家伙。然后你做了，当你开始练体操时，我也练过体操，我做过，我擅长鞍马和地板动作什么的。是啊，但我没坚持下去。但是，肖恩，在紧要关头，你现在能做一个后手翻，就像一个空翻吗？我现在这个阶段可以做侧手翻，但我年轻的时候可以做所有那些动作，是啊，只是做一点点。
Andrew, gun to your head right now. Would you be able to do like a half-ass floor exercise? Yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah, 100%. No way. Yes. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I'd throw my back out.
安德鲁，现在拿枪指着你的头。你能做一个半吊子的地板练习吗？是啊。是啊，是啊，是啊，100%。不会吧。是的。是啊，是啊，是啊。我会闪了我的背。
My knees would be fucked and I'd be ruined. Just pay me a picture. Why is the gun to the head to do this? What is this? Some oligarch is like, I have Andrew Gaffield. You, boy. Do something else. Do it.
我的膝盖会废掉，我会完蛋的。给我一个画面。为什么枪指着头要做这个？这是什么？某个寡头说，我有安德鲁·加菲尔德。你，男孩。做点别的。做吧。
Fucking what? Should I end up in this scenario? I would lose my head. I would not be able to do much of anything. I don't think I'd be able to do a somersault. Yeah. Yeah, well, you could try. Yeah.
他妈的什么？我应该陷入这种境地吗？我会失去理智的。我什么都做不了。我不认为我能做一个空翻。是啊。是啊，好吧，你可以试试。是啊。
And then you left gymnastics. Your father became a swimming trick because then you were swimming. I mean, and then... But just, I'll finish the thing about... So my mom basically was like, I'm out. I'm not. I don't want to be here anymore in L.A. Sorry to go back to that.
然后你离开了体操。你父亲成了游泳教练，因为那时你在游泳。我是说，然后……但是只是，我会讲完关于……所以我的妈妈基本上就像，我走了。我不。我不想再待在洛杉矶了。抱歉又回到那个话题。
I felt like there was a weird thing where there's a thread undone. She got tired of the 90 freeway and she wanted to get out of that. She got tired of the 90. And she said, are you coming? not don't worry kind of thing and my dad was like okay I guess we'll we'll go back we'll go back to England so I was raising England and then yeah gymnastics and I love gymnastics I really did like the first time I did like a back handspring or a back somersault yeah I felt like I had unlocked some weird secret code to my body and to like fly it felt like flying it was very very cool
我觉得有一种奇怪的感觉，就像有一根线没理顺。她厌倦了90号高速公路，想离开那里。她厌倦了90号公路。她说，你来吗？不是那种“别担心”的语气，我爸就说，好吧，我想我们得回去了，我们得回英国。所以我是在英国长大的，然后是体操，我真的很喜欢体操，真的。第一次做后手翻或后空翻时，我觉得自己解开了身体里某种奇怪的密码，那种感觉就像飞翔，非常非常酷。
yeah and then it became something you know you know what happens when you're a kid and you're like good at something and you have a father who you know is a quite a competitive animal. Yeah. It starts to become less fun because suddenly, you know, it's either a gold medal or you, you know, you don't get love. No, not literally, but like in some people. Yeah, for sure.
是啊，后来它就变成了一种……你知道当你还是个孩子，擅长某件事，而你父亲又是一个相当好胜的人时会发生什么。是的。它开始变得没那么有趣了，因为突然间，你知道，要么拿金牌，要么你就得不到爱。不，不是字面意思，但在某些人身上确实如此。是的，肯定的。
I know what you mean. The guys are just kind of like laughing at me. Like, like, like twice. No, I know. Wait, so then, so then you stopped doing that because it got a bit too stressful. Yeah. How soon after that did you find acting and was he supportive of that? Well, yeah, this is what's kind of beautiful, is that we, so I was swimming for, he was my swimming coach for a while, and again, that became another thing.
我明白你的意思。那些家伙只是在笑我。就像，就像，就像两次。不，我知道。等等，所以你后来就不做了，因为压力太大了？是的。那之后多久你才发现表演的？他支持吗？嗯，是的，这正是美妙之处，我们……有一段时间他是我的游泳教练，那又变成了另一回事。
And I kind of just let everything go when I was a teenager, because, yeah, it's like one of my favorite movies. It's like the Truman Show. It felt like the Truman Show. I was like, if this is all there is, there has to be more. And I was being raised in a kind of small town in the south of England, and I didn't have any kind of idea that a life in the arts was a life to be had. I thought it would leave you destitute because kind of on heroin. That was the kind of like the horror stories that were being kind of given to me. And then I, it was my mom.
我十几岁的时候就放手了一切，因为，是的，就像我最喜欢的电影之一。就像《楚门的世界》。感觉就像《楚门的世界》。我在想，如果这就是全部，那一定还有更多。我在英格兰南部的一个小镇长大，根本不知道艺术人生也是一种选择。我以为那会让你变得一贫如洗，因为……大概是海洛因之类的。那是当时灌输给我的恐怖故事。然后，是我的妈妈。
My mom saw how kind of lost I was. And thankfully, I was that loss because without being lost, I wouldn't have found the thing that really set me up for the rest of my life, hopefully, which was, I tried painting, I tried music, I tried sculpting, and I was fine at them and I enjoyed them. But then when I did my first acting class, I did my first play, which was, I played Fat Sam and Bugsie Malone at my local community theater. And it was one of my favorite movies, the Alan Parker movie is one of my favorite movies of all time.
我妈妈看到了我有多迷茫。谢天谢地，我经历了那种迷茫，因为如果没有那种迷茫，我就不会找到那件真正为我余生奠定基础的事情。我尝试过绘画、音乐、雕塑，我做得还行，也挺享受。但当我上了第一堂表演课，演了第一部戏时，我在当地社区剧院演了《龙蛇小霸王》里的胖山姆。那是我的最爱之一，艾伦·帕克的这部电影是我有史以来最喜欢的电影之一。
Yeah. And I felt a kind of close, I felt close to myself in a way that I maybe hadn't felt. I felt a sense of purpose. And then I had a drama teacher that came into high school that kind of mentored me and saw me and said, I think you have something to give here. And that was kind of all I needed. And then, yeah, I had to, weirdly, my dad was very resistant at first. because he was just scared, like any good boomer father
是的。我感到一种亲近感，一种我以前从未感受过的与自己的亲近。我感到了一种目标感。后来高中来了一位戏剧老师，他指导我，看到了我的潜力，说，我觉得你在这方面有天赋。这就足够了。然后，奇怪的是，我爸起初非常抵触，因为他很害怕，就像任何一个优秀的婴儿潮一代父亲一样，
would be of me not surviving as an actor. He was very, very concerned with me just having a roof over my head and living. And also, I thought that was interesting when I read to that point, that you grew up with no money and then your family started this business, then went bankrupt, and then, you know, from there,
担心我作为演员无法生存。他非常非常担心我能不能有个遮风挡雨的地方，能不能活下去。而且，我读到那部分时觉得很有趣，你从小没钱，然后你家里开了公司，后来破产了，然后，你知道，从那以后，
it was just like, God, what am I... I'm sure that feeling that your dad had for you was partly because of that. Well, he's been trying to forget it, but thanks for bringing it up. Talk about the dark. darkest time in your family's life, Andrew, real quick. So then was he really like a hard ass about, well, yeah, fine, you can do the acting stuff,
就好像，天哪，我到底……我敢肯定你父亲对你的那种感觉部分是因为这个。嗯，他一直试图忘记那段往事，但谢谢你提出来。安德鲁，快说说你家里最黑暗的时期。所以他当时真的很强硬吗？比如，好吧，你可以搞表演，
but you're going to go to college, you're going to study a backup career? Yeah, business. He wanted me to go into business, whatever that means. And did you? No, no, I did, like, at A-level, which is like an SAT in business in England, and it was, I got a B, he was fine. But I'll tell you a cool story. So I go to drama school for three years, and he kind of backs me.
但你必须上大学，必须学习一个备用职业？是的，商业。他想让我从商，不管那意味着什么。你去了吗？没有，没有，我参加了A-level考试，相当于英国的商业SAT，我得了B，他也就没说什么。但我给你讲个酷故事。我去了戏剧学校三年，他算是支持我了。
He's like, okay, if this is what you want to do, I'm going to help you do it. So I did three years. After high school. After high school, three years university course in acting at a great drama school called Central, which I loved. And then I started working in theater, but I was still having to, like, do a bunch of odd jobs and Starbucks. I was a cricket coach for a while. I did a lot of, you know, waiting tables, the usual thing. But then, you know, there was a couple of moments on the journey on the way that he, that me and him really started to connect.
他说，好吧，如果这是你想做的，我会帮你。所以我读了三年。高中毕业后。高中毕业后，在中央戏剧学院读了三年的大学表演课程，我很喜欢。然后我开始在剧院工作，但我还是得做很多零工，在星巴克打工。我当过一段时间板球教练。我做了很多，你知道，端盘子之类的事。但是，你知道，在这一路走来的过程中，有几个时刻我和他真正开始建立了联系。
One was getting Spider-Man, obviously, and I kind of, I think I called him straight away. I was like, fuck that business degree motherfucker. Your boy made it kind of thing. And he was like, you don't have to worry anymore. And then I did Death of a Salesman, which is a great play that I did. Philip Seymour Hoffman. And yeah, Mike Nichols directing. And he came and saw that opening night.
一个是拿到《蜘蛛侠》的角色，显然，我想我立刻就给他打了电话。我说，去他妈的商业学位。你儿子成功了。他说，你不用再担心了。然后我演了《推销员之死》，那是一部很棒的戏。菲利普·塞默·霍夫曼主演。迈克·尼科尔斯导演。首演之夜他来看了。
and it was like a lot of whatever dynamics we had to heal father and son dynamics we kind of started to really heal through me doing that play and him seeing me do that play and realizing that we had we had some wounds that we shared that it is generational that it is handed handed down generation to generation these this not enoughness wound or whatever that I think a lot of men have I certainly do that I work with all the time but and then the kind of The third, and it kind of was revealed in my discussions with him that he had this unmet dream of wanting to be a writer. He's a very charming, charismatic, storytelling guy. He's very, he's into art and culture. He's just, it's just been a buried dream of his for a long time. So it was super interesting. And he would tell the story of driving past Fox Studios when he was, he had a shipping company in L.A. And a moving company in L.A.
那就像是……无论我们之间有什么父子间的隔阂需要修复，通过我演那部戏，他看着我演，意识到我们有一些共同的创伤，那是代际相传的，一代传一代，这种“我不够好”的创伤，或者其他什么，我觉得很多男人都有，我肯定有，我一直在处理。然后，在我和他的交谈中，揭示了他有一个未实现的梦想，就是想成为一名作家。他是一个非常有魅力、有感染力、擅长讲故事的人。他很喜欢艺术和文化。这只是他埋藏已久的梦想。所以这超级有趣。他会讲起他以前开车经过福克斯制片厂的故事，那时他在洛杉矶有一家航运公司。还有一家搬家公司。
He would drive past Fox Studios and just imagine, dream and wonder what was happening behind those gates. And there was a night where he was out with my mum to visit me in L.A. It was the night before the Oscars where I was nominated for the first time I was nominated for an Academy Award. And I said, hey, there's a party tonight. I want to take you guys to. And yeah, he's like, where is it? Where we go? I'm like, oh, no, you'll find out. And we're driving. And he's like telling stories about L.A. and his memories of L.A. And we start pulling up to Fox. And he's like, oh, Fox. This is where I used to dream and wonder.
他会开车经过福克斯制片厂，想象、梦想并好奇那些大门后面发生了什么。有一天晚上，他和妈妈来洛杉矶看我。那是奥斯卡颁奖典礼的前一天晚上，我第一次获得奥斯卡提名。我说，嘿，今晚有个派对，我想带你们去。他说，在哪？我们要去哪？我说，哦，不，你会知道的。我们开车过去。他讲着关于洛杉矶的故事和他对洛杉矶的记忆。我们开始驶向福克斯。他说，哦，福克斯。这就是我以前梦想和好奇的地方。
And we start pulling in to the Fox lot, which is where that night before party is held. And he looked at me and he just started bawling his eyes out. And I was like, well, you're going to find out that it's actually not that interesting what happens on the other side of these cases. But at least you'll know. And we had a really beautiful breakfast the next morning, the day of the Oscars, because we are competitive people
我们开始驶入福克斯片场，那是举办前夜派对的地方。他看着我，开始泪流满面。我说，好吧，你会发现那些大门后面发生的事情其实没那么有趣。但至少你会知道。第二天早上，奥斯卡颁奖日，我们吃了一顿非常美好的早餐，因为我们都是好胜的人，
and we like winning stuff, but it's also been very tied in with our sense of identity, our sense of selves as kind of Garfield men. And we kind of healed a lot of that, but still it was a beautiful thing to be able to share, like, a big achievement of like an Oscar nomination with my dad in that way. Incredible. It's amazing.
我们喜欢赢，但这与我们的身份认同感、我们作为“加菲猫式男人”的自我意识紧密相连。我们修复了很多那样的创伤，但能以那种方式与我父亲分享像奥斯卡提名这样的大成就，依然是一件美妙的事情。不可思议。太棒了。
What a great story. As a Garfield man, as you said, as you said, do you hate Mondays? No. Do you love lasagna? Yeah. Very good. You have a dog, me notice. Yeah.
多好的故事啊。作为一个“加菲猫式男人”，正如你所说，你讨厌星期一吗？不。你喜欢千层面吗？是的。非常好。我注意到你有一条狗。是的。
Do you, I love that you had that moment with your dad and that he was able to express, like, in a really sort of real, emotional, unguarded way, how he felt. And what a great lesson to learn from your dad. Even, you know, you weren't a kid anymore. But even just to see, to get that kind of example of that, I think is really, really important
我喜欢你和你父亲有那一刻，他能够以一种非常真实、感性、毫无防备的方式表达他的感受。从你父亲身上学到这一课真是太棒了。即使，你知道，你已经不再是个孩子了。但仅仅是看到，得到那样的榜样，我觉得真的非常非常重要，
and so meaningful, man. Is he still with us, Andrew? Oh, very much so, yeah. He's in England, yeah, yeah. He's writing, and now he's writing. Like, he's just writing for pleasure, and he's really talented, and he's, yeah, we have the, like, I think the proudest thing of my life
而且非常有意义，伙计。他还健在吗，安德鲁？哦，当然，是的。他在英国。他在写作，现在他在写作。就像，他只是为了乐趣而写，他非常有天赋，而且，是的，我们有……我想我一生中最引以为傲的事情，
is my relationship with my dad. And to see, as you say, Will, it's like to see someone allow themselves to evolve in that later stage of life through their kid as their kid is trying to bring, break free and evolve and individuate and free themselves of something that's holding them back from feeling fully joyful in their life. It's so, I tip my hat to him.
就是我和我父亲的关系。正如你所说，威尔，看到一个人允许自己在生命的后期阶段通过孩子去进化，当孩子试图挣脱、进化、实现个性化，并从阻碍他们感受生命中完全快乐的事物中解放出来时，这太棒了。我向他致敬。
And you being old enough to see your father as a co-adult, you know, somebody, like, as we get older, our parents become so human to us. It can be off-putting at times, but also just, you know, obviously really enlightening. It's amazing how we all become sort of equal as we get older. Yeah, yeah, I think, and I've seen you, I've seen you speak on, and I've seen sort of quotes of yours over the years talk about, one of the things that I love about you is the way that you talk about your, how open you are about various things.
而你已经足够成熟，能把父亲看作一个共同的成年人，你知道，随着我们变老，父母在我们眼中变得如此人性化。有时这会让人感到不安，但也确实非常具有启发性。随着年龄增长，我们都变得平等，这真是太神奇了。是的，是的，我想，我见过你谈论，也见过你多年来的一些引语，我喜欢你的一点是，你谈论各种事情时是多么开放。
You've talked about grief quite openly over the last few years in a way that I think is so, it's so admirable in the way that you're able to do that. It really sets such a great example. And certainly just for me, John Q. Public, to read that and see you talk about really touch me and allowed me to kind of go like, oh, I want to be that open. I want to be as in touch with my feelings about certain things.
过去几年你非常公开地谈论悲伤，我觉得这非常令人钦佩。它确实树立了一个很好的榜样。当然，对我这个普通大众来说，读到这些，看到你谈论这些，真的触动了我，让我觉得，哦，我也想变得那么开放。我想在某些事情上与自己的感受保持联系。
I think it's pretty awesome. That means a lot. That's great. Well, you had now a famous quote, Andrew, about grief, which I love, which is, you said grief is all the unexpressed love. Yeah. And I thought, I was like, oh, I had to think about that. I was like, oh, yeah, because I try to tell people how I feel now,
我觉得这太棒了。这意义重大。太好了。好吧，安德鲁，你现在有一句关于悲伤的名言，我很喜欢，你说悲伤是所有未表达的爱。是的。我想，我不得不思考那句话。我想，哦，是的，因为我现在试着告诉人们我的感受，
even if it makes them uncomfortable or me uncomfortable. I don't want to save all that love and emotion for when they're dead or I'm dead. It's like now's the time, you know? But even with, and even with that, even with saying, my relationship is, you know, talking about my mother who passed away just before, in 2000, end of 2019. Even with, because I told her I loved her all the time, even with all that, there was still,
即使这让他们感到不舒服，或者让我感到不舒服。我不想把所有的爱和情感都留到他们死后或者我死后。就像现在就是时候，你知道吗？但即使是这样，即使是说，我的关系是，你知道，谈论我母亲，她在2019年底去世了。即使因为我一直告诉她我爱她，即使有这一切，仍然有，
there still is this kind of chasm of grief that's never going to be fully, you know, the love is, that was the remarkable thing in that experience for me was like, oh shit, like, the love is truly never-ending. Like, it's like, it's infinite. It's like, it's infinite. And it doesn't stop just, it won't stop when I die.
仍然存在这种悲伤的鸿沟，永远不会完全……你知道，爱是……那是我在那次经历中最非凡的事情，就是，哦该死，爱真的是永无止境的。就像，它是无限的。就像，它是无限的。而且它不会停止，它不会在我死时停止。
I don't know. I found that quite, quite touching and quite beautiful. And yeah, I guess, like, I remember being a young actor and looking up to certain people and wanting them to be as real as possible in the world, not just in their films or in their plays
我不知道。我觉得这相当、相当感人，相当美妙。是的，我想，我记得作为一个年轻演员，仰望某些人，希望他们在这个世界上尽可能真实，不仅仅是在他们的电影、戏剧，
or in their music. I wanted to feel like it was okay for me to be as kind of fucked up as I was in the head and in the heart and in the body. And so I don't know. I find it interesting to kind of try to deconstruct the rules of our culture. It's like, why can't we talk about how fucking shitty it is to lose your mind?
或者音乐中。我希望感觉到，即使我的头脑、心灵和身体里有些混乱，也是没关系的。所以我不知道。我发现尝试解构我们文化的规则很有趣。就像，为什么我们不能谈论失去理智是多么该死的可怕？
Like, why is grief a taboo thing? It doesn't make any sense to me in our culture. So it was kind of fun to be able to have fun. It's kind of a light way of putting it. Like, I didn't expect so many people to feel a resonance or a kind of freedom because of that. But yeah, it was a very, it's a very, yeah, I find it very beautiful. Well, it's also we're a little bit, I think as actors, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we, we get the privilege, the opportunity to explore so many different parts of ourselves and emotions as well, that, you know, you have to because the script says, you know, you're going through a breakup or something like that.
就像，为什么悲伤是一个禁忌话题？这在我们的文化中毫无意义。所以能有这种乐趣……这是一种轻描淡写的说法。我没想到会有这么多人因为这个而产生共鸣或感到一种自由。但是的，这非常……我发现它非常美妙。好吧，这也是……我想作为演员，我们……我们……我们……我们……我们……我们……我们……我们有幸有机会探索我们自己和情感的这么多不同部分，你知道，你必须这样做，因为剧本说，你知道，你正在经历分手之类的。
And you have to sort of like explore all that stuff. And so maybe just the idea of dealing with that in your own personal life is not such a foreign and scary thing because we tend to be practiced at some of these kind of oddly shaped emotions and characters. right yeah no definitely it's it's a nice part of it and on that Andrew what it what you know you do you do so much great work and play so many different characters um in different genres and different formats um what is it that um what is it that you like most about what you do um to just ask you like the most base sort of simple question i mean there's so many different parts to it but yeah is Is there one thing that if you, the same guns to your head, you have to say, what is the thing that? I have this fucking Garfield at my disposal.
你必须探索所有这些东西。所以也许在个人生活中处理这些事情并不是那么陌生和可怕，因为我们往往习惯于处理这些形状奇怪的情绪和角色。对，是的，不，绝对是，这是其中美好的一部分。说到这个，安德鲁，你做了这么多出色的工作，扮演了这么多不同的角色，在不同的类型和格式中，你最喜欢你所做的事情的什么？只是问你一个最基础、最简单的问题。我的意思是，它有很多不同的部分，但如果……如果有人拿枪指着你的头，你必须说，那件事是什么？我有这个该死的加菲猫供我差遣。
One more question, Mr. Garfield. Why does he have so much access to me? How does he like, how is he always in the room? This guy, I own this fucking guy. Because you told him your room number. That's what it was. Fuck. We'll be right back.
再问一个问题，加菲猫先生。为什么他能这么频繁地接触我？他怎么总是出现在房间里？这家伙，我拥有这个该死的家伙。因为你告诉了他你的房间号。就是这样。该死。我们马上回来。
and back to the show. Is there one thing that gets you most excited when you open up your eyes to start your work each day? Oh man. Yeah, I mean, it's hard not to be oh God, overly sincere about these things, but it's like it's a life-saving job. I think this job will save my life
回到节目。当你每天睁开眼睛开始工作时，有什么事情让你最兴奋？哦，伙计。是的，我的意思是，很难不……哦天哪，对这些事情过于真诚，但这就像是一份救命的工作。我认为这份工作会救我的命，
in the sense that like, I remember, do you guys read the Agassi autobiography? No, but I've heard I should. I hear that's great. It's so good. And it's about, an athlete and an athlete that hates the sport, he hates tennis. The first line is, I hate tennis.
从某种意义上说，就像，我记得，你们读过阿加西的自传吗？没有，但我听说我应该读。我听说那本书很棒。太棒了。它是关于一个运动员，一个讨厌这项运动的运动员，他讨厌网球。第一行就是，我讨厌网球。
And it's like him and his father and all this stuff. And he has this moment in the middle of the book where he's like, I played for the U.S. Olympic team and we won gold. And I'm stood there with my fellow USA players. And I thought to myself for the first time, maybe I love tennis. And I found that so deeply moving. because for me it's like if I can be a part of a team, if I can be a part of a community that's doing something
那是关于他和他的父亲以及所有这些事情。他在书的中间有这样一个时刻，他说，我为美国奥林匹克队效力，我们赢得了金牌。我站在我的美国队友身边。我第一次对自己说，也许我爱网球。我觉得这非常感人。因为对我来说，如果我能成为团队的一部分，如果我能成为一个社区的一部分，做一些
that is greater than each individual and it's somehow of service in some way and if I get to go to all these emotional places that we're not allowed to go to in other areas of our life, I feel just like so alive, so joyful to be alive and like the luckiest person in the world. So it really feels to me when it's about like if it's about some kind of service to something greater,
超越每个人的事情，并且在某种程度上是一种服务，如果我能去到我们在生活中其他领域不被允许去的那些情感之地，我感到如此鲜活，如此快乐，就像世界上最幸运的人。所以对我来说，当它关乎某种对更伟大事物的服务时，
some spiritual kind of pursuit, then I'm like it's... And the team effort of it too, yeah? Yeah, there's a collective thing. And the majority of the things I do have that kind of quality. I think I do seek out a kind of that kind of quality. Certainly with like the uprising, it's about revolution and it's about what happens when the soul of a person or the soul of a group gets abused and kicked and beaten
某种精神上的追求，那么我就觉得它是……还有团队合作，对吧？是的，有一种集体的东西。我做的大部分事情都有那种特质。我想我确实在寻找那种特质。当然，就像《起义》一样，它是关于革命，是关于当一个人的灵魂或一个群体的灵魂被虐待、踢打和殴打时会发生什么，
to the point where it says, no more, I either die or we change everything. Like, that's an amazing journey to try to understand and go. And obviously, like, universal, like throughout history. And right now, there's people who are feeling that soul squeeze to the point of shit has to change, or today is a good day to die in the pursuit of that change. Right. the money. You know, no.
直到它说，够了，要么我死，要么我们改变一切。就像，那是一个令人惊叹的旅程，去理解和经历。显然，就像，普遍的，贯穿历史。而现在，有些人正感受到那种灵魂的挤压，到了必须改变的地步，或者今天是为了追求那种改变而死的好日子。对。钱。你知道，不。
What about, what about, what about, what about, what about, what about like, location, like part of the world? Like, how much, do you, how much time do you take when you consider these jobs? Because imagine you've got a bunch of different choices that conflict. Do you consider where you're going to be on the planet? How long it's been since you've been home? That's a new thing for me. I'm thinking about that more as I get older, I think. I think, like, in my 20s and 30s, it was like, I'll go anywhere at any time and I'll devote myself
那关于……关于……关于……关于……关于地点，比如世界上的某个地方呢？比如，当你考虑这些工作时，你会花多少时间？因为想象一下你有许多不同的冲突选择。你会考虑你将要在地球上的什么地方吗？离你上次回家有多久了？这对我是个新事物。随着年龄增长，我考虑得更多了。我想，在我的20多岁和30多岁时，就像，我会随时去任何地方，我会以一种可能有点不健康的方式投入到
to this in a way that's probably a little unhealthy. But now I definitely feel, I don't know, man, like, shit, time is ticking. Like, it's not, like, that awareness that it's not forever. Where is home? Sorry, where, where, where is? London. I'm mostly in London, but I'm a little bit in L.A. as well
这件事中。但现在我确实感觉到，我不知道，伙计，就像，该死，时间在流逝。就像，它不是……那种它不会永远持续下去的意识。家在哪里？抱歉，哪里，哪里是？伦敦。我大部分时间在伦敦，但我也有一点时间在洛杉矶，
where you guys are, I think. Yeah, yeah. What is it when you consider taking something that's in a far away land and going to be gone for a while. What are the top three things that you think you're going to be missing and that you're going to be sacrificing? Is it certain relationships?
你们所在的地方，我想。是的，是的。当你考虑接受一个在遥远国度并要离开一段时间的工作时，你认为你会错过的、你会牺牲的前三件事是什么？是某些关系吗？
Is it certain creature comforts? No, it's all relationships, really. Like, it's all relationship. But it's also my home and my relationship to my home. Like I've created a little home for myself in London that it feels like an old friend at this point. So whenever I'm there, I feel like, oh, yeah, this is. this is where I can just be. And, yeah, and my family, I'm very close to my family.
是某些物质享受吗？不，都是关系，真的。就像，都是关系。但也是我的家，以及我与家的关系。就像我在伦敦为自己创造了一个小家，此时它感觉就像一位老朋友。所以每当我待在那里，我就觉得，哦，是的，这就是……这就是我可以做自己的地方。而且，是的，还有我的家人，我和我的家人非常亲近。
I'm very close with my nephews and my brother and my dad still. And, yeah, my old friends are from high school. That's like my closest friends. Yeah, that's what I was going to say, yeah. Are you still, is that still your sort of friend group? All your friends from high school? Yeah, friends from, I have a core group of about five or six friends from high school. And like, that's like, I think that they've certainly saved me from myself.
我和我的侄子们、我的兄弟，还有我父亲依然非常亲近。而且，是的，我的老朋友是高中同学。那是我最亲密的朋友。是的，我正想说这个。你还是……那仍然是你的朋友圈吗？你所有的朋友都是高中同学？是的，朋友来自……我有一个由五六个高中朋友组成的核心小组。而且，我想他们确实把我从我自己手中拯救了出来。
They've got to be thrilled for you. did they have a comfortable time, a decent time sort of adjusting and adapting to them sharing you with the world? They fucking love it. They love it because not only can they ride the coattails, they can also rip the piss out of me. They have free rain. They have like green light to fuck with me.
他们一定为你感到激动。他们适应你与世界分享他们这件事的过程顺利吗？他们他妈的爱死这个了。他们喜欢它，因为他们不仅可以搭顺风车，还可以嘲笑我。他们有完全的自由。他们有权随意捉弄我。
What have you taken the most heat from? Oh, Jesus Christ. I mean, every week there's something. They took a good run at you on Spider-Man, right? Yeah. I think, I think. I think when they see me trying to be sexy in any way, in like an award show,
你被嘲笑得最厉害的是什么？哦，天哪。我的意思是，每周都有那么一件事。他们在《蜘蛛侠》上狠狠地损了你一顿，对吧？是的。我想，我想。我想当他们看到我试图以任何方式表现得性感时，比如在颁奖典礼上，
or if I'm like, let's see it. Let's see it. Give me the steamy look. You look at me in the eyes. Maintain eye contact. Andrew, I just have one Spider-Man question, and I won't go on and on. This I did not know that is it true
或者如果我像……让我们看看。让我们看看。给我那个性感的眼神。看着我的眼睛。保持眼神交流。安德鲁，我只有一个关于蜘蛛侠的问题，我不会没完没了地问。这个我不知道，是真的吗
that you and Toby McGuire each have an actual species of spider named after you? and apparently Tom Holland does not. Is that right? Yeah, but Tom Holland has a gazillion dollars, so I think it's fine. Yeah, but that's cool. Is that true?
你和托比·马奎尔每个人都有一个以你们名字命名的真实蜘蛛物种？显然汤姆·赫兰德没有。是真的吗？是的，但汤姆·赫兰德有数不清的钱，所以我认为这没关系。是的，但这很酷。是真的吗？
Yeah, I believe so. It's one of those things that you've kind of forget happened because it's just too abstract to be able to kind of... Was it a Garfield spider? I don't, I honestly don't know, Sean. Okay, well, our arachnologist named the Iranian species Pritha Garfielda. Garfieldi. No way.
是的，我相信是这样。这是那种你会忘记发生过的事情之一，因为它太抽象了，无法……那是加菲猫蜘蛛吗？我真的不知道，肖恩。好吧，我们的蛛形纲动物学家以你们的名字命名了一个伊朗物种，叫Pritha Garfielda。Garfieldi。不会吧。
And Felista Dada Maguirei in honor of you guys. That's pretty crazy. Now you know. Wow. And none of those words I probably... So it is customary for me with someone like you
还有Felista Dada Maguirei，以纪念你们。这太疯狂了。现在你知道了。哇。而那些词我可能……所以对于像你这样
who's done so much theater to ask if you have any crazy theater stories always start with one of my own just to make you feel like it's okay to share. Mine is I just did this one man's show called The Unknown and I played all 10 different characters. Wow!
做过这么多戏剧的人来说，我习惯问你有没有什么疯狂的戏剧故事，总是先讲一个我自己的，让你觉得分享也没关系。我的是，我刚演了一个独角戏叫《未知》，我扮演了所有10个不同的角色。哇！
Oh, that's one. It felt like... 20 men. Bring it to Broadway. He was insane. Now is the same actor. This Russian guy is everywhere. He's now made his way to the back of the theater.
哦，那是一个。感觉就像……20个人。把它带到百老汇去。他疯了。现在是同一个演员。这个俄罗斯家伙无处不在。他现在已经到了剧院后面。
Italian guy. No, but he's made his way into the back with the Italian guy. They still can't find him. He just runs around from aisle to aisle. Yeah. And every night I'll look at the back. Canadian David Fincher is somewhere in the mix here as well. I'd like to think of myself as the Canadian David Fincher.
意大利家伙。不，但他已经和那个意大利家伙一起到了后面。他们还是找不到他。他只是在过道之间跑来跑去。是的。每天晚上我都会看后面。加拿大人大卫·芬奇也混在其中。我喜欢把自己看作加拿大人大卫·芬奇。
Sorry, go ahead. Sean, what's your theater story? So my theater story is one night, one man's show, I played 10 characters. One night, one of my characters, asks another character question, and I stood there waiting for the answer for a really long time. And then I go, oh, shit, I'm that guy, too. I swear to the guy that, like, after 50 shows, your mind starts to go crazy. And I asked the question to the character, and I was literally waiting for the answer.
抱歉，请继续。肖恩，你的戏剧故事是什么？所以我的戏剧故事是，有一天，独角戏，我演了10个角色。有一天，我的一个角色问另一个角色问题，我站在那里等答案等了很久。然后我说，哦，该死，我也是那个家伙。我发誓，演了50场之后，你的大脑就开始疯狂了。我问了那个角色问题，我真的在等答案。
I was like, oh, I'm that guy, too. Oh, my God. It was the worst feeling. It was so scary. That's called like a mini mental breakdown That's like Coalcephosis I think Totally
我说，哦，我也是那个家伙。哦，天哪。那是感觉最糟糕的一次。太可怕了。那叫迷你精神崩溃，我想那叫“Coalcephosis”，完全是。
But anything in Angels in America Or Death of a Salesman or anything Oh yeah I mean yeah definitely I think it was one of the first previews of Angels in America that we did in London And it's after a you know It's a nine hour show
但在《天使在美国》或《推销员之死》里有什么吗？哦，是的，我的意思是，是的，绝对有。我想那是我们在伦敦演的《天使在美国》的预演之一。那是在一个……那是一场九小时的演出，
And it's the first time we're doing You know all of it back to back on a Saturday And yeah Fuck And I can't I don't know how that I don't know how any of us survived it Truly like it's ridiculous
这是我们第一次在周六连续演完所有部分。是的，该死。我不知道我们是怎么活下来的。真的，太荒谬了。
But there's a big climax at the end of the second part where I have to fight an angel on stage. And the angel is on a harness, and at one point she goes up on wires, and I'm like holding onto her, and I'm like pulled around the rafters, like off the ground during this very, very technical fight. And to get set, I have to put my hands through loopholes by her waist,
但在第二部分的结尾有一个大高潮，我必须在舞台上与一个天使搏斗。天使系着安全带，有一次她被吊在钢丝上，我抓住她，在这一场非常、非常技术性的打斗中，我被拉着在椽子上转，双脚离地。为了准备好，我必须把手穿过她腰间的环，
and I'm wearing like a hospital gown with my ass out, facing the audience. And I'm like, okay, it's our first time doing this in front of an audience. And I get set and I'm like right down at the front of the stage. My ass is towards the audience. And I'm like pretending to wrestle this angel. And I'm like set, set, set. And then nothing happens.
我穿着一件屁股露在外面的病号服，面对观众。我在想，好吧，这是我们第一次在观众面前做这个。我准备好了，就在舞台最前面。我的屁股对着观众。我在假装和这个天使摔跤。我在想，准备，准备，准备。然后什么也没发生。
We just stay on the ground. We're meant to be lifted. So we're just like on the ground, on the ground. And as we all know, like just the awful feeling of having to pretend like everything is fine. And so I'm like continuing to wrestle. I'm just kind of like doing the worst continual wrestle movement with my ass facing the audience. And I think it's about a minute and a half
我们只是留在地上。我们本该被吊起来的。所以我们只是在地上，在地上。正如我们所知，那种必须假装一切正常的糟糕感觉。所以我继续摔跤。我只是在做最糟糕的持续摔跤动作，屁股对着观众。我想大约有一分半钟，
that I'm just doing this one impossibly awful movement. The guy backstage is trying to find the right rope to pull. And the stage manager, who is this very sweet, nerdy, northern guy, comes out. And like the dramatic music starts. and I'm still doing this awful wrestle that's the time makes the show. And the guy goes, I'm so sorry, everybody.
我一直在做这个不可能的、糟糕的动作。后台的家伙在试图找到正确的绳子来拉。舞台监督，那个非常可爱、书呆子气的北方人，走了出来。戏剧性的音乐开始了，我还在做那个糟糕的摔跤动作，时间决定了演出。那家伙说，非常抱歉，各位。
We've had some technical difficulties. We'll be right back with you. After like eight hours of a show, the curtain comes down, and my ass is still to the whatever, and the curtain comes down, and we fix it. And I get back in the position after like five minutes. I stick my ass at the audience again, and the curtain comes up, and I'm still doing the wrestle.
我们遇到了一些技术困难。我们马上回来。演了八个小时后，幕布落下了，我的屁股还是对着那个什么，幕布落下了，我们修好了。五分钟后我回到位置。我再次把屁股对着观众，幕布升起，我还在摔跤。
And, of course, like, it works, and the audience go fucking crazy. crazy because that's what they want. They want the worst shit that could possibly happen to happen and it to be recovered and they're part of like something that could never have happened otherwise if they'd come in the other night. But it was
当然，它成功了，观众们疯狂了。疯狂，因为这就是他们想要的。他们想要最糟糕的事情发生，并且被挽救回来，他们参与了一些如果他们那天晚上没来就永远不会发生的事情。但那是……
I'm sweating talking about it. Do you actually just made a really good point about the sort of, they're part of something that can never happen again the exact same way or otherwise. Is that part of the allure to you of theater? I wonder what you guys think about this.
我谈到它时都在出汗。你刚才确实提出了一个很好的观点，关于他们参与了一些永远无法以同样方式再次发生的事情。这是戏剧对你的吸引力的一部分吗？我想知道你们对此怎么看。
I feel like, I mean, maybe this is a very obvious thing to say, but I feel like that's where we're heading now. We're heading back towards live immersive experience. A hundred percent. It feels like one of the last commodities that is going to be valued. The one thing AI can't do. Well, yeah, in-person experience. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
我觉得，我的意思是，也许这是一个非常显而易见的说法，但我感觉这就是我们现在的方向。我们正在回归现场沉浸式体验。百分之百。这感觉像是最后一种将被重视的商品之一。人工智能做不到的一件事。嗯，是的，面对面的体验。是的，是的，是的。
Like an actual live... Whether it's comedy or music or theater or storytelling. It's going to be a huge, yeah. I think so. I don't know. And also, what about like orchestral music too, right? which is what it used to be. There was no recordings of anything.
就像真正的现场……无论是喜剧、音乐、戏剧还是讲故事。这将是一个巨大的，是的。我想是这样。我不知道。还有，管弦乐音乐呢，对吧？那才是它过去的样子。没有任何录音。
You had to go to the opera house or whatever it was and watch Beethoven conduct his symphonies. You could buy an album and hear it. Gun to your head. What symphony are you going to listen to? Amher cocked. Compose something. Now, Andrew, you know, Jason and Will know
你必须去歌剧院或任何地方，看着贝多芬指挥他的交响曲。你可以买一张专辑来听。枪指着你的头。你会听哪部交响曲？阿姆，作曲吧。现在，安德鲁，你知道，杰森和威尔知道，
and people know I love every once in a while like having a gummy. Just because it's relaxing. A weed gummy. A weed gummy, yeah. And you once celebrated... Define every once in a while. Yeah, what's this every once in a while, Gary?
人们也知道我偶尔喜欢吃一颗软糖。只是因为这很放松。大麻软糖。大麻软糖，是的。你曾经庆祝过……定义一下“偶尔”。是的，这“偶尔”是什么意思，加里？
Did you run out? Garbage. Yeah, I did run out, actually. I need some more. You once celebrated turning 29 by eating pot brownies at Disneyland. Please tell me how that went. Yeah, it was one of the old-time...
你吃完了吗？垃圾。是的，我确实吃完了。我需要更多。你曾经通过在迪士尼乐园吃大麻布朗尼来庆祝29岁生日。请告诉我那是怎么回事。是的，那是老时光……
Great days. Yeah, no, it was one of the all-time great days. Did you ride rides, though? I think I would puke. Yes. No, no, no, I did, and we didn't. One of us did. George did. George had to get off crew. Like, what's that California? Where you're kind of like...
伟大的日子。是的，不，那是史上最伟大的日子之一。你坐过游乐设施吗？我想我会吐的。是的。不，不，不，我坐了，我们没有。我们中的一个坐了。乔治坐了。乔治不得不下船。就像，那个加州的是什么？你有点像……
Oh, yeah, California. California. Yeah, he couldn't... We wrote that a few times. He only... He could only manage two times. And, yeah, so George had a tough run of it for a moment. We all had tough moments. It was like a group of like eight or nine of us, and we all kind of got each other through those kind of trenches moments. And it was great. Each one of us dipped at a different moment, so it was like a little bit like whack-a-mole. There was like a corn dog moment that we had where I was really struggling Oh hang on
哦，是的，加州。加州。是的，他不能……我们坐了几次。他只能……他只能应付两次。所以乔治有一段时间过得很艰难。我们都有艰难的时刻。我们大约有八九个人，我们都互相帮助度过了那些艰难的时刻。这很棒。我们每个人在不同的时刻掉队，所以就像打地鼠一样。有一个热狗时刻，我真的很挣扎。哦，等等。
But there was one really I think the best moment The best moment was the simplest moment of the day weirdly Where we transitioned from Disneyland to the California Adventure Theme Park part of Disneyland And there's that song
但有一个真的，我认为最好的时刻，最好的时刻是那天最简单的时刻，奇怪的是。我们从迪士尼乐园过渡到迪士尼的加州冒险乐园部分。有那首歌，
California here we come right back Where we started from That was coming emanating from the speakers in the trees And one after the other We all looked around and realized that we were all doing the exact same jaunty little walk dance to that song.
“加州我们来了，回到我们开始的地方”。那首歌从树里的扬声器里传出来。一个接一个，我们环顾四周，意识到我们都在随着那首歌做着完全相同的轻快小步舞。
Like happy bears. Like we were doing the exact same and it was like... That's funny. It sounds like there could have been some caps and stems in these pop dionies. No! It was purely weed.
就像快乐的熊。就像我们在做完全相同的事情，而且就像……那很有趣。听起来这些布朗尼里可能有一些迷幻成分。不！那纯粹是大麻。
But we were so aligned. We were so aligned. We were aligned with the cosmos in that moment. Apart from, and we had, you know, it was fancy. It was like 29th birthday, so we pulled out all the stops. We got one of the guides to take us around, one of those lovely Disney guys. And her name was Chantal. And she may have been an AI robot because she did not betray any knowledge of what was moving through our system.
但我们太同步了。我们太同步了。那一刻我们与宇宙同步了。除了，我们有，你知道，这很高级。那是29岁生日，所以我们全力以赴。我们找了一位向导带我们四处看看，那些可爱的迪士尼员工之一。她的名字叫尚塔尔。她可能是一个人工智能机器人，因为她没有表现出任何关于我们系统里正在发生什么的知识。
She was just so like, she was like Disney adult, joyful. I think they're pretty accustomed there now to folks just tripping balls when they go down. There's like there's two kinds of people. There's either like the wholesome family, you know, get the little kids and the strollers and all that stuff or the people above. There's the shaggy-haired actors, yeah, with their buddies. If you're 25 years and older,
她只是那么……她就像迪士尼成年人，快乐。我想他们现在已经习惯了人们在去那里时磕药了。有两种人。要么是那种健康的家庭，你知道，带着小孩和婴儿车之类的，要么是上面那种人。那是长发演员，是的，和他们的哥们。如果你25岁以上，
you're probably on something. I can't do, I can't do roller coasters and stuff anymore. No, me neither. My equilibrium's gone after 50s. I'm shot. Yeah, I get nauseous. I think I might be the same. I think I might be the same.
你可能吃了什么。我不能，我不能再坐过山车之类的了。不，我也不能。我50岁以后平衡感就没了。我完了。是的，我感到恶心。我想我可能也一样。我想我可能也一样。
I went to you, I was in Universal Studios recently with an old friend from high school, we went, just, I don't know, we just went, and we had a pot, a kind of little pot candy, and we had a guide as well, and I felt like she was cool enough because we did the Transformers ride, which is one of those, like, it's a screen, and it's 3D,
我最近和一位高中老友去了环球影城，我们去了，只是，我不知道，我们只是去了，我们吃了一点大麻糖果，我们也有一个向导，我觉得她很酷，因为我们坐了变形金刚游乐设施，那是那种，就像，它是一个屏幕，它是3D的，
and it's like a fucking hell. It's just pure fucking hell. It's like, it's Dante's Inferno. It's just horrible. And we came out, and both of us, I was worse, I was like, I'm really fucked up now in a way that's not pleasant in any way. I would blow chunks everywhere.
这简直是该死的地狱。这纯粹是该死的地狱。这就像是但丁的《地狱篇》。这太可怕了。我们出来时，我们两个，我更糟，我当时想，我现在真的搞砸了，以一种一点也不愉快的方式。我会到处呕吐。
And I was too high and I was too dizzy and I turned and I was like I trust this girl I'm gonna see I'm gonna see what she says I'm like hey I don't know if you're aware but I we did a little bit of we got a little bit high before the Transformers ride and now I'm regretting it and she was so fucking cool
我太嗨了，太晕了，我转过身，我想我信任这个女孩，我要看看她说什么，我说，嘿，我不知道你是否知道，但我……我们在变形金刚游乐设施前吃了一点，现在我很后悔，她太他妈酷了，
she was like I got you we're gonna go to Hogwarts we're gonna go get a butter beer we're gonna go and we're just gonna sit on a bench and we're gonna have a place where there's a really nice breeze we're just gonna ride this out we're just gonna ride this out this ain't my first rode I'm high right now too. She's like, check out this ride.
她说，我懂你，我们要去霍格沃茨，我们要去喝黄油啤酒，我们要去坐在一张长椅上，我们要去一个有凉爽微风的地方，我们要熬过这个，我们要熬过这个，这不是我第一次这样了，我现在也嗨着呢。她说，看看这个游乐设施。
It's called a bench. Now, Andrew, I believe we've kept you way too long. Jason said something to me a long time, which I love. He goes, when after he's worked his balls off on something like this movie or whatever, or Will's in the same boat, and I read that you're kind of similar, Jay said, I want to aggressively do nothing when this is over, just for a little bit, for a day or a week or whatever. and you recently said your perfect day off
它叫长椅。现在，安德鲁，我相信我们留你太久了。杰森很久以前对我说了些话，我很喜欢。他说，当他在像这部电影之类的事情上拼命工作后，或者威尔也一样，我读到你也有点类似，杰说，当这一切结束后，我想积极地什么都不做，就一会儿，一天或一周之类的。你最近说你完美的一天休息
would be a lot of lying down and looking out the window which sounds incredible how long can you do that for before you're like up and up and again up and around again? I can do it for a couple of months like I like oh god yeah I really can I've been working for like 11 months straight
会是躺着看窗外，这听起来太棒了。你能那样做多久，然后你又会起来四处走动？我可以那样做几个月，就像，哦天哪，是的，我真的可以。我已经连续工作了11个月了。
and it was so schizophrenic like doing the I did like Sam Altman who's like an emperor and then I did the peasant movie where I play the opposite of an emperor, someone who's getting kind of abused by an emperor figure, and then doing Roy and like doing Roy Horn
这太精神分裂了，就像我演了像萨姆·奥特曼那样的人，他就像个皇帝，然后我又演了那部农民电影，我在里面扮演一个与皇帝截然相反的角色，一个被皇帝式人物虐待的人，然后又去演罗伊，就像演罗伊·霍恩一样
from like 20 years old to 65 years old. Like we do the whole gamma. So I feel, you know, you get to the point sometimes where you're so deeply resentful of the work that you love to do so much. And that's kind of, that's kind of, of where I'm at. And then what is your version of looking out the window?
从20岁演到65岁。我们经历了整个过程。所以我感觉，你知道，有时候你会达到那种程度，对你曾经非常热爱的工作感到深深的怨恨。这就是我现在的处境。那么你发呆时的状态是什么样的？
Is it watching dumb TV? Is it reading books? Is it hanging out with friends? I would like to say it's reading books, but it is more watching dumb TV. And literally looking out, I have a lovely window in my house. And there's a beautiful tree that I just stare at.
是看无脑电视吗？是读书吗？还是和朋友闲逛？我想说是读书，但更多时候是在看无脑电视。真的就是发呆，我家里有一扇很漂亮的窗户。外面有一棵美丽的树，我就盯着它看。
Again, it's like this kind of like the most valuable commodity outside of live performance is quiet and time and space and not having our attention snatch. by the things that were always snatching our attention. But no, yeah, friends, I did a trip to Devon, which is a little seaside town in England with my nephews and my brother. I did a trip with friends to Greece.
再说一次，这就像是除了现场表演之外最宝贵的商品，那就是安静、时间和空间，而不是让我们的注意力被那些总是抢走我们注意力的东西所占据。但不是，是的，朋友们，我和我的侄子还有我哥哥去了一趟德文郡，那是英国的一个小海滨小镇。我和朋友们去了一趟希腊。
I did a little driving around Italy. Yeah, I mean, like, yeah, tending to that part of the garden, being with my family, simple shit. I love that. One of the gifts of, like, being raised the way I was is it was made very, very clear to me by osmosis, I think that there was no way that I could ever allow myself
我在意大利开车转了转。是的，我的意思是，是的，打理花园的那一部分，和家人在一起，简单的事情。我喜欢那样。像我这样被抚养长大的礼物之一是，我想通过潜移默化，我非常非常清楚地意识到，我绝不能允许自己
to drink my own Kool-Aid enough to lose myself. You know what I mean? That's why I keep my close friends close who will keep me accountable and keep me. I love that, pal. Well, thank you for being here. This is a great episode. I laughed so hard with you.
沉溺于自己的那一套而迷失自我。你知道我的意思吗？这就是为什么我与亲密的朋友保持密切联系，他们会监督我，让我保持自我。我喜欢那样，伙计。好吧，谢谢你来到这里。这是一期很棒的节目。我和你一起笑得太开心了。
Thank you. I love you guys. I think you guys are so phenomenal. I'm such a huge fan of you guys and I'm grateful for this podcast and for everything you guys give to the world. I really, really truly am sincerely. Well, likewise.
谢谢。我爱你们。我觉得你们太了不起了。我是你们的超级粉丝，我很感激这个播客，感激你们为世界所做的一切。我真的，真的，非常真诚地这样认为。好吧，彼此彼此。
Right back at you. Yeah, I'm sincerely right back at you. And if you don't, we'll put a gun to your head and we'll say keep going. Yeah. Have fun in New York, Andrew Garfield. Pleasure to meet you. Much love to you.
同样的话送回给你。是的，我真诚地把这句话送回给你。如果你不这样做，我们就拿枪指着你的头，让你继续。好的。在纽约玩得开心，安德鲁·加菲尔德。很高兴见到你。给你满满的爱。
Yeah, it's so great. Love to you, pal. Great talking to you. See you around, I hope. All right. Yeah, cheers. Bye, pal. Thank you.
是的，太棒了。给你满满的爱，伙计。和你聊天很愉快。希望以后还能见到你。好的。是的，干杯。再见，伙计。谢谢。
Bye. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. That's, that's a, I like that guy. A lot. I do too, man. Me too, a lot, a lot. Yeah, what a easy, breezy conversation. I love it.
再见。再见，再见，再见，再见，再见，再见。那是个，我挺喜欢那家伙的。非常喜欢。我也一样，伙计。我也是，非常非常喜欢。是的，多么轻松愉快的谈话。我喜欢。
You'd ever consider being our friend? Yeah, let's ask him. He would be a good friend. Can we send him like, what do you, do you, how do you make friends nowadays? You just, like, send an offer. But we don't want to come on too strong, though. Send an offer.
你有没有考虑过做我们的朋友？是的，我们问问他。他会是个好朋友的。我们可以给他发个什么，你，你，你现在怎么交朋友？你只是，就像，发个邀请。但我们不想表现得太强势。发个邀请。
Yeah, you know. Who would you rep by? This is just our starting point. Please feel free to counter. Is that how you started? I just. I'm always amazed that. Actors like that go from job to job to job to job.
是的，你知道。你由谁代理？这只是我们的起点。请随时还价。你们就是这样开始的吗？我只是。我总是很惊讶。像那样的演员从一份工作跳到另一份工作，接连不断。
When do you have time to create the character, like, and get and figure it all out? Do the research and all that stuff? Or how about this? How about when do you have the time to, like, not be an actor and hang out and, like, maybe, like, meet some nice guys like us and create new friendships and, you know. Or wait, you're still lobbying for him to be your friend. Yeah, I mean, Jesus, you know. You know what, Jay, you know what you do? He probably gets so many great opportunities.
你什么时候有时间去塑造角色，去弄清楚这一切？去做研究之类的？或者这样呢？你什么时候有时间不去当演员，去闲逛，去，比如，见见像我们这样好的人，建立新的友谊，你知道的。或者等等，你还在游说他做你的朋友。是的，我的意思是，天哪，你知道。你知道吗，杰伊，你知道你该做什么吗？他可能得到了太多好的机会。
He can't stop, you know. Yeah. Yeah. You know how you make a new friend. You meet somebody. Jesus. You go really slow. You get to know them.
他停不下来，你知道的。是的。是的。你知道怎么交新朋友吗。你遇见某人。天哪。你要慢慢来。你要去了解他们。
So short. And you go, you just take it slow and you take it day. Bye. Bye time. Day time. Day by time. Oh, you didn't get it. Oh, you didn't get it.
太短了。然后你走，你只是慢慢来，一天。再见。再见时间。天时间。一天天。哦，你没听懂。哦，你没听懂。
Smartless. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Rob Armjarf, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Grant Terry. Smartless. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Smartless。Smartless是由罗伯·阿姆贾夫、贝内特·巴比科和迈克尔·格兰特·特里百分之百有机且手工制作的。Smartless。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子来发表评论。